I've been a fan of yours for many many
years I think you're one of the funniest
people in the world
I've been a fan since Mad TV days 20
years ago today with uh with tigerbelly
so given that given your status is a
world-class comedian
how did it feel that you were not
invited to Andrew Schultz's wedding and
I was
you were there yeah I was there
I was the least funny person there and
the whole time I was thinking
isn't that funny that Bobby Lee's not
here yeah um
all my life I always felt like people
didn't like me and didn't want to invite
me to things you know I mean I think
that's fundamentally
the reason why I do what I do so it
really did hurt a lot
and um I had resentments I did some
Revenge fantasies about how I'm gonna
get revenge on him and stuff yeah and
him specifically him specifically okay
like have a big wedding invite everyone
you know I mean accept him stuff like
that yeah and then just write him a
letter like see that's how it feels or
whatever but instead of that I'm because
I've been therapy and stuff I'm just
kind of like trying to let it go what
did you do there this right here why'd
you do that I forgot to start the timer
and now let's start over yes let's do
this
let's do it again take two no uh you
still feel like an outsider your
exceptionally successful made domain you
still feel yeah you know I'm doing a
Netflix show tonight with Andrew Santino
at The Comedy Store and this and that
but like last night you know I just felt
like I wasn't a part of in fact on stage
I go I even mentioned that I go Netflix
they don't like me you know what I mean
and I just say things like that
um they're not true and this is
something that I want to correct with
myself because I have this internal
dialogue that's based
on just the past and 99 of the things
that go on in my mind aren't true and
I'm just at a point in my life where I'm
just don't want to start I want to start
I don't want to live like that anymore
really because I'm the same way I'm
deeply self-critical all the time yeah
and um that's kind of an engine that
drives you to to do stuff yeah but it
doesn't give you the kind of Freedom
that I would like don't you want to be
truly free free from your mind
free from negative thoughts
no I am free part of the day and some of
the day I spend being extremely
self-critical and that drives you
because I'm afraid I'll become Ultra
lazy otherwise because I love life I
love being comfortable I love just
relaxing I need very few things in life
and so I'm afraid I'll just get like
super lazy oh
are you a minimalist yeah so if I went
to your house in Austin do you have a
couch
I recently got this is the first college
I've gotten ever because the guests were
complaining because I also record uh the
podcast there the guests are complaining
there's nowhere to sit I have no chairs
no couch I sleep on the floor like a
mattress is on the floor
um not not out of principle I think out
of some kind of uh minimalist momentum
minimalism so we're the opposite in that
way then oh so you like stuff
I'm not a hoarder but because I can
throw things away but I have a shopping
addiction I think
like when I'm on the road like I was in
Oklahoma for two weeks I just I bought a
bunch of stuff you know what I mean and
then
oh my God I went to Todd Snyder and I
bought um how about these shoes
you know
because you know but you're wearing them
so they're they're actually you're using
them and they're giving value to your
life that's awesome yeah but this is the
last time I'm gonna wear these this is
one time this is like a wedding yeah
it's a Red Carpet Dress who's the
designer do you know I don't know
anything what are you wearing Bobby I
don't know what I'm wearing but I
because I'm on a native show called
reservation dogs right I just want to
get into the spirit of things that's
your yeah this is because if I was ever
like native and I was in a tribe back in
the day you know what I mean I would
have been a gatherer
no I'm I'm gonna weave baskets with the
ladies yeah I want to pick berries with
the ladies you wouldn't be the chieftain
no no and I would make after the hunt I
would probably make some so some of the
guys make love to me
oh
yeah because I'm kidding up just because
you know yeah yeah yeah there's a power
heart and you got to know your place in
the hierarchy yeah your alpha male then
I don't even know what that means Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan is the definition of
alpha meant to me yeah if like if there
was a picture of alpha male in the
dictionary
yeah yeah
yeah
so you hoard stuff okay yeah yeah but
you can throw it when was the last time
let me call you out on that when's the
last time you threw away something
that's actually valuable
valuable like something valuable to you
or valuable in general most things that
I buy aren't valuable to me there are
things that are valuable to me that are
like keep stay sakes from my family and
stuff that I will keep forever so I like
in terms of like an old photo of my
father or whatnot so those kind of
things I keep but um when it comes to
like you know Aviator Nation sweats like
if some of like somebody came over to my
house and goes hey can I have six of
those sweatshirts or whatever I'd be
like yeah go take it okay my brother's
come over to my house and she's done a
clearance you know I mean like I'm gonna
take this this is I generally
really don't have a problem with this is
a self-critical voice is serving no
purpose in terms of because you're
pretty you know I've I'm a fan of yours
so you're known to be a little bit lazy
sometimes 100 lazy yeah yeah so the
self-critical voice don't you think that
it's
serving a purpose and fighting off the
laziness beating off the laziness
the self-critical voice that I have I've
been able to come up compartment how do
you say compartment yeah however you say
you're free yeah yeah put it in a
compartment yeah right and
um I'm able to like um I'm a good
avoider I'm good at avoidance so for
instance right now
um to avoid I I've been playing stardew
Valley you know what that is no it's a
phone game or no it's a um you can play
it on your switch but it's on the Xbox
and it's a farming simulation game and
so I like to farm you know what I mean
and so in playing video games and doing
stuff like that distracts me from you
know what really is going on okay you've
mentioned elsewhere in terms of video
games Elder Scrolls yeah did you play
that yeah of course it's probably my
favorite game if I could live in a world
you played Morrowind and Skyrim and I
played Oblivion Oblivion I played a
little bit of Morrowind but I didn't
like the graphics back then but I really
played the can I swear on this podcast
yeah I played the [ __ ] out of um
Oblivion and Skyrim like
eight characters played it all the way
through I have to do all the quests that
type of thing what's your favorite thing
about those games
um why did you spend so much time in
that world because I I like games that
you can grind
what do you mean by Grind so like
stardew Valley for instance right
there's a lot of back to the pharmacy
right okay it's the same thing as Skyrim
the reason why I like it is that there's
a lot of like I have to collect a lot of
these things you know I mean I have to
just constantly pick things up you know
what I mean yeah like for instance in
Skyrim there's a mushroom called blister
wart mushroom that you can pick and then
you can make it into at some sort of
formula right yeah potion yeah that
potion yep so I would spend like
literally human 12 hour days just going
to every cave and picking up as much
blister work as I could like that kind
of grinding
you know what I mean yeah yeah so you're
actually the randomly generated quests
that these kids do yeah for people like
you yeah you don't get bored that's the
that's the fun yeah that's the fun for
me okay yeah there's always something to
do and I find like when when you play a
game that's linear like there's certain
games where you have to go this way
right I don't like games like that yeah
I like open world games where I can make
choices and I can grind if I want yeah
yeah would you stay in that world if you
could live in that world in the in the
Elder Scrolls world that's how I feel
in reality or become like a animated
thing in there oh no say like virtual
reality we're moving towards that
direction oh yeah if you look at Skyrim
you mentioned Graphics it's become
it's starting to get realistic yeah like
I I I'll sometimes just walk around I
mean it's been a while but I'll just
walk around in Skyrim yeah you can uh
there's code you can turn off enemies
and you just walk around really you can
just listen to music and just walk
around that's what you did yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I would do that when you
do that would you do it with me you sure
we would have a house together oh I mean
live I thought walk around no no no if
you and I were able to go into Skyrim
right and walk around and live together
would we make love no no no man don't go
there okay no no no no because we like
girls man yeah that's right it's not gay
well you told me it's not gay yeah it's
not yeah yeah all right so you and I
would yeah I would hunt you would gather
but in that world uh there's no hunting
yeah but there is hunting I would do we
have the because we don't have to find a
Bandits we have to fight I'm not gonna
gather or abandon I'm gonna hunt them
but I thought you said it's all about
the potion you don't need the bandits
okay well we could do this we could you
could be the guy that like defends our
place yeah right I'll gather all the um
blister award all the White Caps all the
mushrooms I'll get all the food I mean
I'll go to White Run remember white run
right or Winterhold and I'll do all the
like crusts that have nothing to do with
you know what I mean so no dragons
though no no dragons but we would have a
banquet we'd invite the dark dark
brotherhood yeah right the Fighter's
Guild we definitely invite them Mages
guilds we'd invite them are you a thief
kind of guy I'm a thief guy yeah for
Life yeah they've got for life and you
still wouldn't invite Andrew Schultz to
that no no no no but what a piece of
[ __ ] though huh because let me just say
something okay I just want to get back
to that okay okay sure so I met him at
the Montreal Comedy Festival and him and
I our Kindred uh Souls we we really
connected yeah
and he did my podcast he's done it
several times done his we've we've like
communicated on the phone this and that
and to me and then he invites Whitney
Cummings which Whitney is a good friend
of mine but what I'm saying is is that I
know Andrew as well as Whitney knows him
I don't think that Whitney knows them
more than I do right what if it was a
competition like it was a tie you know
and like NBA like a Bobby Lee versus
Whitney yeah why in what way do you
think she's better in what way do you
think you're better I think it's all
about gender Optics
he has all these alpha males coming and
he's like all right I can I have one
more seat left yeah Whitney or Bobby but
Bobby is although I don't think there
was a lot of Koreans there so he could
have used that card this is true right
but I think he went for you know
Whitney's a woman it's better for Optics
okay so she was a diversity higher for
the wedding yeah
I see it was it was pretty fun it was
pretty I have to say I don't
is Joe Rogan yeah I know his wife forget
it yeah and then uh Whitney uh those are
the only comedians that were there
I spent the whole time talking to Jose I
I think no I don't think there was that
many comedians so I'm kind of joking
about it was a pretty pretty small
wedding yeah